once upon a time I had a publishing
company I had software I had employees I
had business licenses I had a bunch of
stuff in a functioning company but when
it came time to sell the company they
said to me we only want to buy your book
list and the contracts with your your
authors and the finished books and
ebooks that are for sale at Amazon why
is that why is it important for you and
me well let's say right now that you
have a couple extra bucks and because of
covid and everything you have a
competitor across town and maybe is
having a tough time you don't want to
buy the company your typical purchase
would be hey how much revenue do you
have what profit do you have maybe I'll
pay you this many times profit well
asset sales in a distressed situation
you're only buying what's in the house
and then you leave the other guy to
close off the house and whatever cost
there are to do that